[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt max
doch was sagen hallo darf deswegen ist
ein kindergarten also so sieht sie dann
aus gibt es nicht so gut geht kann ein
bisschen bauchweh gehabt ja aber jetzt
geht es besser wenn du mit mama backen
darfst oder perfekt wir packen heute
eine zitronen tat mit einer richtig
schönen oberfläche also mit einer pc
kruste und die zitronen tat besteht aus
einem mit zitronen kriegen und dann der
wm asse machten citronella kaspar
stuttgart am spiegel den zitronen sauer
ja kommen wir zeigen mal kurze zu tun
wir zeigen wir kurz die märkte daten
werden teilt verwenden wir 70 gramm
zucker wo ist der zucker 140 gramm
kalter butter 210 gramm mehl genau wie
lexmark etwas salz
eigelb und eine normale jetzt die
zutaten hier alle innen sondern mixa ihr
könnt aber auch den mut mit der hand
vernähten oder manchmal gerät oder und
der küchenmaschine ja das icon nur nicht
hier oben drauf ok am besten immer in
die schüssel mal und dann noch aus
katzen so damit wir alles benutzen
okay es ist ein gutes rezept denn du
kannst du einfach alles reinschmeißen
[Musik]
das haben
super und von der zitrone neben den
abrieb und deswegen ist auch ganz
wichtig dass die unbehandelt ist damit
man eben auch die schale mit verzeihen
können sich mal hallo das riecht gut
sagt nicht das macht man nicht
aber wir wollen das jetzt in der
maschine
dabei hebt oben rein und den mac einfach
ganz kurz verrühren
er soll immer schön kalt bleiben hatte
sich maschine betätige ich okay
[Musik]
ausstechen
okay aber den wollen wir jetzt erstmal
noch nicht ausstechen
den müssen wir nämlich kühl stellen also
den teig gebe ich jetzt hier auf einen
teller sind flach drücken so kühl dann
nämlich richtig schön und schnell ab
nochmal probieren dann abdecken und für
etwa eine stunde kalt stellen und ich
werde in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
zutaten zeigen will die zitronen könnte
die zitronencreme brauchen wir jetzt
ohne die sind auch unbehandelt und da
brauchen wir die schale und 200
milliliter saft
ok dann brauchen wir noch 150 gramm
zucker 100 konzerne fünf eier 2 eigelbe
und 30 gramm stärke 9 11 spielt am
liebsten im zucker von der zitrone
nehmen wir jetzt die zitronenschale
wirklich nur das gelbe und nicht das
weiß und die inhalte darf damit die
zitronen so ein bisschen massieren damit
vergleich 200 milliliter und die auch
massieren jetzt darf ich noch mal dient
als möglich schale dran dazu bringen sie
in der branche dabei ist er ab und zu
noch ein deswegen schlägt das ist dein
lieblingsessen leberwurstbrot geflügel
leberwurst
das mache ich meine das ganz scharf ist
okay wir sind eine ganz scharfe reiben
wenn man damit finger drauf kommt dann
blutet ganz okay das macht die mama guck
mal ich geb dir mal die eier
hier kannst du schon mal rein schritten
langsam dann die 2 eigelbe super und
wieder auskratzen dann den zucker
stärke ist ein toller assistenzbedarf
nur den chinesen nicht runterfallen
lassen sondern macht viel sauerei wir
jetzt mit der hand und alles immer schön
alle zutaten in einen topf und ich kann
jetzt schon mal den zitronensaft
auspressen davon 200 milliliter und dann
alles gut verrühren supermacht es besser
als der papa
[Musik]
egal was sie macht es strecke hatte
da machst du rein und ich ertrinke da
jetzt verrühren wir alle zutaten richtig
gut miteinander und dann stelle ich den
herd auf mittel hohe hitze und lass die
masse so ganz langsam eindecken
nein das reicht das machen wir jetzt zu
schätzen
das darf man nicht drängen kennen ja ich
will es manchmal auch kein trinken als
lecker schmeckt erwartet darf
die zitronen creme dieses eingedeckt
sicher auch sahne creme wie mein level
curt nur eben mit sahne stadt mit butter
und ich habe sie jetzt nicht aufkochen
lassen aber ihr seht schon sie ist
richtig schön dickflüssig und der
vorgang der kann schon so fünf bis zehn
minuten dauern die sich jetzt vom herd
runter und hier denke ich auch auf der
oberfläche mit frischhaltefolie ab damit
sich keine haut bildet das kann einfach
hier kurz auf der seite dann gleich
stehen bleiben und ich kümmere mich dann
so lange um den teig her aussieht wie
sie es normalerweise nie so backen mit
kindern ist eben ein bisschen anders
jetzt habe ich hier den abgekühlten teig
und kneten einmal kurz durch und
manchmal verkürzt sich die fahrtzeit
einfach indem ich den teig kurz ins
gefrierfach stellen da brauche da nicht
eine stunde sondern wirklich nur eine
viertelstunde hatte 15 minuten
[Musik]
und jetzt mit wenig mehl auswahl
und ich nehme jetzt gleich meine 30 cm
tat form und rollt den teig deswegen auf
etwa 32 cm aus zwei 30 bis 34 also ein
bisschen rand darf ruhig sein
den rest kann man ja wegschneiden dann
am besten mal mit einer palette darunter
damit es nicht an klebt jetzt nämlich
hier eine top form mit hebe boden so
bekomme ich die tat später nämlich
richtig gut wieder raus die form fertig
jetzt dann kann ich den teig auf meinen
außenstadt aufräumen und in die form
legen jetzt den teig darüber legen und
die form damit auskleiden
wenn der teig irgendwo reißt es gar
nicht schlimm
nehmt einfach so ein kleines stück fügt
sie dran und dann schön die form damit
auskleiden hier oben nämlich den rand
immer gern weg mit einer palette oder
mit einem messer zum beispiel kann es so
schön glatt und knapp zähler
super was die kekse bevor ich den teig
jetzt stelle ich ihn noch mal für etwas
zehn minuten in den gefrierschrank sowie
der noch mal schön kalt und behält beim
backen auch seine form
er las texte haben wir jetzt im ofen ich
hatte übrigens noch eine portion teig
gemacht weil ich nämlich wusste die wir
bestimmt auch krieg zu machen und den
teig hier den steche ich jetzt ein damit
er beim backen nicht aufgeht
falls aber doch auf gerät ist auch nicht
schlimm den kann man später einfach
wieder runter drücken und den teig werde
ich jetzt erstmal verpacken und später
kommt am erste füllung 1
[Musik]
jetzt die tat vor geboten
doch schön flach geblieben ich hier an
der einen stelle ist ein bisschen hoch
aber da nehme ich jetzt einfach eine
burger presse und kann sie hier so ein
bisschen vorsichtig runter drücken
möchte ich hier nur ganz minimal und
jetzt nehme ich hier die zitronencreme
die habe ich gerade durch das fleißige
lieschen gestrichen damit einfach
klümpchen weggestrichen werden jetzt
hier auf die tat streiche theoretisch
müsste man die creme jetzt nicht mit
backen aber ich bucks setzten bisschen
mit damit es einfach business mit
festwirt von schreibt eben so richtig
schön sie vorsichtig verteilen
und jetzt kann ich die tat noch mal ein
bisschen weiter backen und nach der
backzeit nehme ich sie aus dem ofen und
kann dann schon mal lieblingsthema
zuzubereiten staates gebacken und könnt
jetzt gerade ab wird ein bisschen risse
auf der oberfläche bekommen aber das ist
gar nicht schlimm da kommt der
biodiversität jetzt mache ich die b&c
schickt dafür den mich jetzt aus zucker
250 gramm eiweiß als 150 hier habe ich
drei eiweiß
salz und das will ich jetzt weil es
jetzt nicht mehr in den backofen kommen
das heißt es im wasserbad gemacht
darunter ist ein topf mit wasser das
kocht jetzt gleich und jetzt kann ich
hier den pc masse verrührt und so werden
einfach alle keime abgetötet und ich
erhitzt die marseille etwa zehn minuten
wenn es wasser zu stark koch stückchen
hätten bis herunter
massa habe ich nach dem erhitzen einfach
vom wasserbad heruntergenommen und sie
kalt gerückt so sieht es jetzt aus
richtig schön fest jetzt kommt die auf
die abgekühlte hat ihr könnt jetzt
natürlich auch mit einem spritzbeutel
auf spritzen oder ganz einfach so mit
einer palette dann fliegt sie auch noch
richtig schöne oberfläche das ja auch
das geld von besuch durchscheinen und am
rand und wenn ihr noch mehr pc haben
wollt dann könnt ihr auch ein eiweiß
mehr nehmen und natürlich auch 50 gramm
mehr zucker aber ich finde es einfach
ein bisschen zu versüßen
so kann sie zum verfährt werden ich
werde dir da noch flambieren das hat
aber mehr optische gründe
ok und der zucker karamellisiert ein
bisschen ich möchte natürlich auch
rettung aus der form heraus und dadurch
dass ich jetzt die tortenplatte
mitgeboten haben also die tat dann
einfach mit einer palette darunter gehen
[Musik]
so kann muss jetzt gleichziehen
die zitronen tat anstalten ein bisschen
[Musik]
und nicht zu süß gab es aber nicht ich
bin zu tag vom band oder gewinnen dem
text ist so schön wir wissen ja dass ich
krank werde noch ein stück raus weil das
foto gehört ja genau das ist ja die l
hatte übrigens keine nutzer die mit
ihren fixen super zufrieden und super
für mich und hat keine lust mehr über zu
packen
dafür darf sie jetzt gleich mitsaniert
ausgehen zum spiel
wir werden jetzt nicht hier gleich die
zitronen bild seht hat essen als ich
finds echt gefreut fruchtig und das so
lücke der spanier holt könnte zum
beispiel auch noch gemeinde machen und
dazu geben da hat er noch von mandel und
wenn ihr das rezept nach macht könnt ihr
mich gerne verlinken
ich wünsche euch jedenfalls ganz viel
spaß zum nachmachen übrigens findet ihr
auch alle meine rezepte auf interest
dann könnt ihr dann alle rezepte also
bis zum nächsten mal
und schreibt mir gerne welche torte als
nächstes
[Musik]